ever since star wars the force awakens
we've seen a major uptick in fan service
that heavily utilizes nostalgia like
bringing back old characters famous
props memorable set pieces and
references and callbacks to the past the
general response to fanservice is
extremely divisive because in some cases
it can come across as exploitative and
other times it can be well integrated
ever since spider-man no way home came
out i feel like it's been a good example
as to how to do fan service correctly
although it's still not perfect so i
want to compare and contrast the good
and bad examples while going over the
three main pillars that make up great
nostalgia based fan service
the first one is that it needs to have a
purpose within the story if it's just
there for the sake of nostalgia then it
can immediately come across as
disingenuous
this is where spider-man no way home
really shines because the old villains
from the prior spider-man movies
actually have character growth obviously
not all of them have a lot of character
growth because there are 5 of them but
the best example in the group is dr
octavius we see him go from being
essentially in his villain prime of
hating spider-man to peter parker fixing
the hardware that's driving his mind
insane and him going back to being a
good person the writers don't use dr
octavius as a one-trick means to garner
nostalgia from fans these villains are a
large part of the focus and by
continuing their story in a satisfactory
way these old characters blend into the
new story to find meaning and we don't
just have character growth for dr
octavius his conflict heavily influences
peter's character arc in the movie he
learns that he'll be partially
responsible for the death of these
villains by sending them back to their
timelines and it's possible to find
another way to save their lives by
curing them which goes against the
stereotypical hero defeating the villain
stereotype so the old villains
positively impact the story because they
force peter parker to change and they
also go through new and interesting
dynamics so don't come across as a
retread like the villains interacting
amongst one another and having some cool
dialogue their interactions to seeing a
new spider-man and being in a different
universe that has new mechanics like
magic more dynamic action and having a
mostly new story also i haven't even
touched on the fact that we have
returning spider-man who get their own
redemption and closure since some of
their stories ended prematurely
comparing this to something like star
wars the force awakens the very purpose
of its own fan service is questionable
because of how much of a [ __ ] the
whole movie is
when lining up a new hope in the force
awakens the plot becomes alarmingly
identical we have one of our main
protagonists who gets ambushed by a
villain who's similar to darth vader and
before getting captured he sends away a
droid with sensitive information then
the droid happens to run into a
force-sensitive person who doesn't know
their parents and escapes off-road in
the millennium falcon they meet an old
experienced character that ushers them
into an expansive story who ends up
dying to the main villain and motivates
our heroes to take down the empire sorry
i mean the first order and destroys the
death star or starkiller base but yeah
you get the point so by crafting a story
that is almost indistinguishable to a
new hope it garners a lot of
exploitative nostalgia because they're
redoing an old story but with a new
layer of paint and all the while the
force awakens is being advertised as a
whole new story so the purpose here for
the movie seems like a cheap and
scientific way to make as much money as
possible by mining nostalgia from fans
you can kind of argue the same for
spider-man no way home but for that
movie they actually tried to do
something new meanwhile in the force
awakens a lot of the nostalgia-inducing
aspects in the movie are contrived like
the millennium falcon coincidentally
being on jakku and rey being able to
expertly fly the ship doing extremely
advanced maneuvers that not even tie
fighter pilots could keep up with and
it's also convenient that the second
they take the millennium falcon off
world they immediately bump into han
solo and chewie so they can have this
nostalgia feels good line
chewing
we're home
or even maz kanana randomly having luke
skywalker's lightsaber for some reason
and she says this where'd you get that a
good question
for another time
it's very clear that the story in this
movie comes secondary to the fan service
and since that's the case once the
nostalgia rose and the glasses effect
wears off the movie becomes much worse
and we actually see the flaws for what
they are
for the second pillar of great
fanservice it has to follow the internal
logic of the movie or in other words it
has to make sense within the established
roles of the movie's world this is where
i think spider-man know home could be
improved because the rules of the
multiverse and how dr strange's spell
works can be a bit confusing and
inconsistent like one of the main
conveniences is that the only two
spider-man and villains that show up are
people we already know as an audience in
theory there should be other renditions
of these characters looking through and
the fact that it's only characters we
are familiar with is convenient for the
story despite that being the most
practical direction to take the story
because you can't just set up a bunch of
different people we don't know so
personally this aspect does not bother
me and it's at least plausible to happen
but for other movies the writing is a
lot worse or is a straight up
contradictory for how they set up the
fan service segments the most glaring
example is ghostbusters afterlife and as
a quick warning i'll be going into some
spoilers for the movie but it's been out
for a while so if you wanted to watch it
you probably would have by now when the
main character who's aegon's daughter
finds her way into a jail cell she
decides to call the old ghostbusters
number for her one phone call which in
of itself is absurd that a child
wouldn't call their parent in this scary
situation but whatever when talking to
ray from the first movie he says this
one morning i go to work connect to one
our old cadillac is gone his new trauma
thrower collider pack all the traps 16
ounces of fuel isotope all gone he
cleaned us out but at the end of the
movie when our heroes are in need of
help peter venkman ray and winston
miraculously show up to save the day
however this moment is immediately
contradicted by what the writers told us
earlier in the movie in that phone
conversation so how did they get their
equipment back when egon supposedly
cleaned them out the writers just seemed
to hope that the audience doesn't ask
any questions and are instead blinded
and awed by the nostalgia of the
original ghostbusters being back on
screen together don't ask how these
three characters somehow got to oklahoma
within an hour's notice of the world
going to [ __ ] or let alone someone
asking these three characters for help
because that doesn't happen in the movie
they basically materialize for a
contrived entrance instead of allowing
the characters we've been following to
solve the problem themselves we're
looking at matrix resurrections which
small spoilers the writers make it to
where the machines bring back neo and
trinity from the dead because their love
for each other generates a lot of power
like what if bringing back characters is
so far-fetched that it physically
doesn't make sense within your own movie
then you need to leave them alone the
only time it's right to bring them back
is if it's purposeful and follows the
movie's internal logic otherwise it
comes across as the studio wanting to
cash in on the nostalgia for the last
pillar of great fan service you can't
rely on nostalgia-inducing references
for entertainment in small doses i think
it's fine especially if it's plausible
for the reference to be made in the
first place like when peter parker is
talking about how he'll be making cures
to save the villains and mr osmore chips
in to say this you know
i'm something of a scientist myself yes
that obviously references the meme but
it can be forgivable since the topic is
on science and he genuinely wants to
help however once you start to use
references repeatedly it drastically
lowers the new story experience because
we are constantly anchored down in the
past the worst defender of this is
ghostbusters afterlife practically a
third of the movie is our new characters
discovering old props and callbacks to
the first ghostbusters movie since our
new characters inherited egon's house
and he raided the ghostbusters and saw
all their equipment the writers send our
main characters into a scavenger hunt of
nostalgia every scene is imbued with the
essence of the leonardo dicaprio
appointing meme or the soy jack pointing
meme as he gushes about something he
just found during these scenes the plot
hits a standstill because there's no
story development in the concept of our
characters walking around and gawking at
props from the first movie and there's
an even more egregious example where
paul road is in walmart for no reason
other than to get food and he runs into
many state-puffed marshmallow men none
of the other food or products in walmart
are being affected by paranormal
activity and it's just coincidentally
the marshmallows it comes across as the
filmmakers injecting the stupid
reference for cheap nostalgia and even
worse a forced merchandising
advertisement if you thought the porgs
were bad then you'll love the mini steak
puffs marshmallows these references
should be second nature as the story
takes to priority like in spiderman no
way home the characters make references
that can easily follow the head of
casual fans while getting ready for the
third act battle toby maguire goes on
about how his back hurts and andrew
garfield offers to crack it during the
moment this comes across as brotherly
bonding between characters that
desperately need love and appreciation
in their lives to my surprise this was
actually a reference to spider-man 2
where he hurt his back and this moment
acts as a kind of easter egg so as long
as the references aren't distracting and
aren't hindering the story with a
massive nostalgia roadblock then it can
definitely work or you can go the crazy
matrix resurrections route where the
movie becomes a meta comedy about
caching on the matrix franchise where
they make tons of references the movie
weirdly becomes self-aware if you don't
break these three rules for fanservice
and it can definitely work within the
movie i'm just tired of so many
franchises falling victim to this and it
comes across as studios and writers
barely trying anymore and think that as
long as you are experiencing nostalgia
then you won't notice the movie's
glaring flaws
you